come here yeah right now you are moving
towards me at the speed of poop 2 cm per
second that is how quickly on average
feces leaves the human body it's about
400s of a mile hour but guess what in
the animal kingdom the larger the animal
the faster its poop comes out elephant
dung races out at 6 cm/ second for the
typical dog though Solid Waste comes out
at only 1
cm/s okay but here's where it gets
really weird the bigger the animal the
longer its poos and their poos are
longer by just as much as they are
faster so if you're an animal on this
planet sure we have our differences but
we share this one thing in common it
takes us each the same amount of time an
average of 12 seconds to fully evacuate
a glob of coup and I think that's
beautiful